in the indonesian capital this former
military compound is now home to
hundreds of refugees from afghanistan
there's little to do here but wait and
worry
it's not a life that we're living we
live in depression we are stressed all
day
sultan has been following news about
afghanistan waiting for information
about the town he left nearly seven
years ago
for more than a month he has not been
able to contact his wife or his mother
day and night i think about them the
taliban has captured malistan i'm
worried and i don't know anything about
how they are
since the taliban takeover there have
been regular protests outside the u.n
refugee agency office and foreign
embassies here calling for refugee
rights and to speed up the resettlement
back to your process
refugees are allowed to stay in
indonesia while waiting to be accepted
by other countries but they are not
allowed to work or go to school
refugee advocates say indonesia should
see itself as more than a transit
country sooner or later
indonesia is going to be not only
transit
but the destination countries and the
government should be aware and prepare
of that
the indonesian government says it
anticipates that more people may try to
leave afghanistan but indonesia is not a
place for permanent resettlement
our policy is clear we are not a
destination country we did not sign any
international convention on refugees
outside the u.n building in central
jakarta a group of young men camps here
every day waiting for news about their
resettlement and hoping to hear from
their families
there are more than 13 000 refugees in
indonesia and more than half are from
afghanistan the long wait to be
resettled is now even more stressful as
they're increasingly concerned about the
people they left behind
abdullah says he hasn't been able to
reach his mother or sister in months
and i have too much stress but i cannot
help myself how can i help my people or
my family afghanistan
like everyone here he worries about his
own future and the fate of his family
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta